i'd like you to draw on your page and
take at least half a page to do it
please
i'd like you to draw a quadrilateral
don't do it yet
but you're going to draw a quadrilateral
with the following properties number one
it needs to be different to the
quadrilateral of the person
next to you or around you i want you all
to have as different kinds of
quadrilaterals as you can
that's the first quality the second one
is try not to make it
like a special quadrilateral try and
make it a bit
random a bit weird looking not like a
square like that's a very specialized
quadrilateral yeah
try and draw something it's a bit
irregular bit strange different to the
person next to you i'll give you about
30 seconds
off you go just through my true
quadrilateral
polygon four sides yep you've got it
okay fantastic
i've got a couple here because um i'm a
chronic overachiever all right now
here's what you need to do
with your quadrilateral and this is
especially why the ruler is not just to
make it like straight and all that kind
of thing you also need to do some
measurements for me here's what you're
going to do
with your ruler i'd like you to find
the midpoint of each of the four
sides that you've drawn you've got four
sides
therefore four mid points go ahead and
measure them out and mark
the midpoints please eyes up for a
second even if you're not quite finished
getting your midpoints you can finish
doing that shortly
maybe your page looks something like
this at the moment i'm hoping
if you do have another color the
secondary color will be useful for this
part
i wonder if as you look at the four
midpoints you've got you notice anything
unusual about them because remember i
asked you to draw what i like to call
not the technical term an unspecial
quadrilateral like some weird random
irregular
thing right you may have even if you're
a smarty pants come up with what we call
a
non-convex polygon because you can see
this thing's jutting in it's got an
obtuse
a reflex angle in there right now
nonetheless
stay hard right you may notice there is
even though
an unspecial quadrilateral what you
started with you've created a very
special shape
with your four midpoints and you'll be
able to see it you can go ahead and do
this now
if you join in a new polygon
each of those midpoints into a new
quadrilateral if you got it there join
them up
and i promise no matter how
weird a quadrilateral you began with
you've created what kind of shape
that's a parallelogram thank you pervani
parallelogram
parallelogram parallelogram now
if you're like i don't believe it right
look at the person who's next to you
this is why i asked you to draw one
that's different
to the person's beside you sure enough
you all have created a parallelogram no
matter what shape you began with
now here's what you're going to do for
the next few minutes and i
invite you to try and work this out with
the people around you
i hope you've been mathematicians long
enough that you look at this
and you start asking questions i mean
one main question right
why why is this happening i started with
something random
and yet like part of mathematics is
there are patterns
everywhere even in places you wouldn't
expect them
now remember we're also doing this under
this heading so you actually have a leg
up on most people who i showed this to
you can prove you have enough knowledge
in your head i promise to prove
why this happens in at least three
different ways i'm only going to focus
on one of them the one which is the
heading
but i just want to give you a few
minutes to play for a moment and try and
talk this out with the people around you
why is this happening i'll give you a
few minutes to have a go make some
theories
and then we'll come back together and
i'll show you how to do this off you go
let's have a go with this now the first
uh pre-loop i'm
going to give to this is i first
discovered this property
way before vectors was introduced into
the extension one extension two
courses and i thought huh like it just
tickled me that something so random
can lead to something so structured and
predictable and that was quite strange
to me felt magic actually
and then i thought why is this true
mathematicians always ask the question
why right now you can prove this i
mentioned at least three different ways
right
the first way is you could put some
coordinates on this thing
you could say oh let's call this x one y
one
x two y two like they're all random
right x three y you just
put some names on things and then start
to apply
coordinate geometry to what you know
here for example
if this was x1 y1 and this was x2 y2
then you know the coordinates of this
spot
what would the coordinates be that'd be
x1 plus two divided by two you're
finding the midpoint yeah
y one etc you get the idea right now you
can do this
it is long and arduous right you'll get
there though
another way you could do it is you could
just use like we're drawing
parallelograms and other kinds of shapes
right you can put some fairly
simple constructions on here and prove
this using similar triangles
it's better than corner geometry but
it's still a fairly long and ideal
process
okay we have somewhat more
powerful tools at our disposal believe
it or not
this entire proof that i'm about to show
you
is two lines and they're not even
long lines emmanuel just looked up at me
because he's like i just wrote my tenth
line uh-oh okay
i'm not saying your method's wrong but
there's a faster way however
we are gonna need to set up our diagram
right so the two lines just
work so if you've got nothing else on
your diagram sorry let me start that
sentence again
if your diagram is now really busy
because you've put all this stuff on it
what i'd advise you to do is underneath
that diagram just
briefly draw a nice neat clean one
because i might put some fairly
different
labels and things like that on here and
we don't want to confuse it with what
you've got okay
here's where i'm going to begin i'm
going to use
vectors to express or describe
each of the sides and lengths that i've
got here
okay now you can do it a bunch of
different ways here's the way i'm going
to do it
see this uh i'm going to call this point
up here in the top left i'm going to
call that like a beginning spot
okay in fact i'm even going to write
beginning here just so you can
see why if i begin there
right i'm going to describe this top
length here as a vector
a vector has think back to less than one
two components what are they
magnitude and direction so i've got a
magnitude which is the length of this
side
but then i have to choose direction and
i could describe that side in at least
two different ways going this way
or going that way right now why do you
think i called this one
beginning where do you think i'm going
to send my vector to the right okay so
let's
put an arrow there right now it's a
vector because it's got direction
and let's just call it a shall we no big
deal
now i'm going to begin up there and i'm
going to keep going right so normally
we think about in geometry we think
about labeling points
but in vector land i'm thinking about
labeling lengths and sides here right
so i've begun up there i'm going to just
keep going around the quadrilateral
right so i've got another vector here
this long one down this side
and very creatively i'm going to call it
b
okay now even though a logical thing
might be to just keep on going around
if we were labeling this the points we'd
call them like capital a capital b
we just go like clockwise right i'm
actually going to return back to the
beginning
just come back over here and i'm going
to label this side
and i'll call it c i'm going to make
this the beginning again
and i've got c here and that makes my
last one
d and it needs direction as well of
course so far so good
okay this is c
this one's c and then this one is d so
two separate vectors
following so far okay fantastic now
vectors have magnitude they have
direction when we take
midpoints right when we take midpoints
this is not a rhetorical question
out of those two things magnitude and
direction when you take a midpoint one
thing changes the other does not
magnitude direction which one stays the
same
direction stays the same if you have a
look at this midpoint here it's going in
the same direction as a
right but its other thing its magnitude
has changed
what operation do we apply to a vector
to keep its direction the same but
change its magnitude
think back it's a lot of complicated
operations one of the very first ones
you learn
you multiply by what what do you
multiply by
a scalar right you multiply by a scalar
okay
because that doesn't change which
direction you're going just changes the
length right makes it longer or shorter
to get to a midpoint what would be the
appropriate scalar to multiply by
it'd be half right because you want to
go in the same direction but only go
half as far
so that would make this vector here
half a do you agree with that this is
also half a
over here as well but i'm actually just
going to leave that for now it's just
going to cloud my diagram
what's this one over here this one over
here
half c right because that's that's c
there half
c i should also put on we should all put
on
the vectors have to have direction as
well so really i should have that arrow
hanging over there and this arrow going
here if i wanted the arrow going in the
opposite direction i'd also have to have
a
minus sign wouldn't i okay so far so
good
now i'm going to come down to here and
maybe the cogs are starting to turn
okay what's this vector here i know i've
left off you're like what happened over
here
you'll see why in a second i'm going to
come all the way down to here what's
going on here
it's half b right they're both half b
this time i'm going to start from the
midpoint and go
all the way to the end so here's another
green arrow in fact i'll even make this
whole thing
green over here just so you can see
where it starts and ends that's
half b and then lastly
i'm going to say over here from this
pinpoint
down to the end let me draw you for you
sorry mrs lee's i'm partly ruining your
whiteboard markers
what's that coming called we've done
four times now this is half d
okay fantastic all right now i promised
this would be a
two line proof we've done all the setup
we need are you ready
i said here's the beginning i didn't
label it but what would you call this
what would be an appropriate name for it
it's the end right you start up there
and you end
down here and one of the things you
might recall um i think we were talking
about associativity
actually when we're doing it is if you
have some beginning
and some end right no matter what kind
of vectors you take to get there
right they're actually going to have in
total
the same value if you start at the same
point you end at the same point
even if this is just called the x vector
if you went a b c d
e f right you add them all up you end
the same spot right so what can you tell
me about the relationships between
a b c and d
being that they begin here and they
end here what could you write what
equation could come
out of that any takers
what do you think
just take a stab in the dark here's why
right i had a math teacher
many many years ago who said to me when
i was a student he said when you get
posed the question
always guess always guess i was like
really
like in the australian mass competition
if you guess you get penalized you said
no always guess here's why
if you're right you will feel amazing
like ah see that's right you can go to
your friends
if you're wrong you'll learn something
could be like ah why is my guess
wrong what's going on in my brain
someone give me something
anything
the addition of the vectors would be the
same is what tyron's saying
i like the idea but i need a bit more
specificity here because i have
a lot of vectors on here which vectors
do i add
it gives me the same thing
a and b what am i doing to them again
i'm adding them a plus b where does it
send you
from the beginning to the end i could in
fact draw like one big diagonal across
here that would be equivalent to a plus
b
and we're saying that's equal to c plus
d because again same start point same
end point
that was line one here comes line two
uh this thing here right the sum of
vectors is itself
a vector right it's the big long one
that i suppose i could just draw
all the way through okay this is also a
vector right
so i can do this same scalar multiple
out the front and it's an equation the
left and right hand side will stay equal
so i'm going to multiply by a half
is that okay
nothing too dramatic so far
believe it or not those are the two
lines that's it
you're still looking at it thinking i'm
not it's not quite clicking for me
okay half
of a plus b that's on the diagram
i just haven't actually put it on yet
where is half of a plus b
where is it how do i think
hmm now is a bit cruel of me
because remember i left off a lot of
stuff on the diagram where is it where
would you put it maya
one of the red lines it's one of the red
lines which one
the midpoint of a to b right remember i
said this is half a this is half a as
well
this is my somewhat like i wanted to
give you clues but not make it too
obvious okay
if this is half a and this is half b
this um
this actual parallel side doesn't help
you it's going the other opposite
direction right
half a plus half b
is this vector right here do you agree
with that in fact let's go ahead and
label that
as the case this is half a plus
half b start here end there
yep where's half c
plus half d it's the opposite side
half c plus half d so that makes this
half
c plus half d
but we just said in our whole two lines
of a proof
that half a plus half b
is equal to half c plus half d
what were the two things that make up a
vector again they are
magnitude which means these two sides
are equal in length
and direction which means these two
sides are
parallel if you have any kind of shape
and the opposite sides are
equal and parallel that's a
parallelogram you don't even need to
worry about the other two sides go ahead
and try it if you want
like draw two sides randomly they're the
same length going the same direction
when you join them it has to be a
parallelogram no matter where
you are now
uh later on as you're going i will show
you what the proofs
by corner geometry and the proof by
slimmer triangles look like i'll put
them up on the screen
they're somewhat nightmarish right
they're the things you want to do if
you're like i'm trying to fall asleep at
night i will write this stupid long
proof
this is a perfect example of the
elegance and power that vectors give you
to prove sometimes things you already
knew and sometimes things you didn't